this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house what's
happening you bad [__] i'm back
like herpes
it's wednesday the 29th of june
the joey diaz project is brought to you
by draftkings listen to me hockey's over
basketball's over but i'll tell you
what's not over the ufc and draftkings
sportsbook the official sports betting
partner ufc has a tremendous weekend
it's ufc
276 whether it's alessano with a
knockout kick or a punch from kenia you
win no matter what listen we got great
fights this weekend we got bolonoski
against max holloway alessano against
jared kenia we got sean strickland's
fighting sean o'malley's fighting and
with draftkings the same game parlay you
can turn a small bet
into a big payday listen there's 12
fights on this card and i don't already
see an upset that's gonna [__] i
looked at it monday pace if you put 25
down you'll win 100 god knows what it'll
be by saturday but for ufc 276 you can
place a same game paulie and if it hits
you win double so if you like volinoski
and jared khamir that's a [__]
ballet download the draftking sportsbook
app today use promo code joey and beth
finals on any ufc fighter to win get a
hundred and free bet no matter what
happens that's code joey this saturday
draftking sportsbook the official sports
betting partner of the ufc minimum age
and eligibility restrictions apply
support the show by downloading the
draftkings sportsbook app
and using code joey if you know someone
who has a grambling problem crisis
conference
referral services can be addressed by
calling 1-800 gambler but if you got no
problems let's make some money it's ufc
276 the joint is also brought to you by
cbd lion
when it comes to cbd
the lion is the best how do i know
three four years running with these guys
from the kinesiology tape to the bat
balls to the cream
david had the cbd hemp and
delta eight gummies
and tincture who's better than cbd line
nobody so go to cbd lion
download the third party lab results and
let's get this [__] party started
press code joey joint or church and get
20 off your first order on any cbd lion
product now without further ado
let's get this [__] party
started jack
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
so
what's up you bad [__]
sorry about monday [__] it's
wednesday the 29th of [__] june
the month is almost over fourth of july
is upon us break out the [__] flags
it's over you know what i'm saying let's
do this [__]
i am [__] i am excited about this
[__] summer for you [__] i
know what you're wondering how was the
birthday how did i do let's get this
let's break this [__] down on a
wednesday
break christ should put together
something i don't know if you guys know
anything about how comedy used to work
in the summers
there was always a tour for years
there was what's the one that uh
whatever it did that i i did the one
year like 2016 with chappelle
and then i did it the second year with
sebastian and dane cook it was a it was
a big tour and then the one year they
[__]
added a bunch of cities they got greedy
and they didn't sell any [__] tickets
a year with sebastian
remember brody used to do the small
stage and all that
yeah that was a great festival you know
but uh i don't know what the pandemic
and the last two years they didn't have
it and all of a sudden i got a call from
burke rice
to do this fully loaded tour i had no
idea i'm not living in l.a so i'm not in
the [__] loop
so when he told me about the fully
loaded toy you know it was a minor
league stadium tour
and uh
i was like you know what this is perfect
i just got to do 15 or 20 minutes i
i think last thursday the first night i
did like 12 minutes i i couldn't think
of material it was but i loosened up
over the tour and everything worked out
but that's not when he told me i just
needed 15 minutes of material
what a way to you know come back into
comedy you know going in front of big
[__] audiences
and uh doing 15 to 20 [__] minutes a
night i that this will let me know what
my fate was and i got to be honest with
you i was very happy how it turned out
the
bert kreischer
did not cut corners you don't know how
much that means to a guy like me
you know
there's these [__] comics that
realize they can't make it so they buy
comedy clubs
or they do something so they can perform
but at the meantime while they're
worried about their dream
they don't treat comics like they like
you should these are your people you
know i'm saying there's no reason why
you shouldn't have a [__] green room
there's no reason
why you shouldn't have
a bag of peanuts to eat you know these
people coming to do a show for you but
comedy club guys like there was a club
in ventura i don't know what the name of
it was that guy didn't want to get me a
hotel one day to do radio okay i
couldn't talk to him after that anybody
knows that if you drive two hours to do
radio and you got to spend the day up
there you got to get a hotel room that's
part of a cheap one i don't need no
threat four seasons i just but he didn't
wouldn't do it a 49 hotel i was gonna
[__] pay for it
so i got a thousand stories where a club
there's a club in [__] tempi the guy
is uh
you know you know he's a [__] comic
never went on the road but you know he
does and he emcees the shows and he
controls you and then he won't [__]
pay you for a week so
these guys that are self-acclaimed
comics get a comedy club i'm always
weary of when somebody a comic gets uh
you know like last summer dave chappelle
did a thing during [__] covert in
ohio he flew everybody back he took care
of them i heard that it was [__]
amazing
and that's what real comics do
you know when a comic comes into your
festival whatever the [__] to do you
take care of him and i gotta tell you
something bert kreischer
took care of me first thing i saw when i
got there was a swag bag
he got me yeti chairs yeti coolers
[__] the coolers with the thermos he
got me t-shirts converse sneakers
[__] slippers a workout thing for
your room when you're in a hotel over
the weekend cables and [__] like that i
don't know what the [__] i mean
the food was second to none
he had tons of food there and to boot he
had my man dave from florida barbecue
and all [__] day brisket
ribs so when you got off the stage at 10
o'clock that place looked like the
[__] like the fountain of youth
everything that was missing with naked
people i mean they had every saturday
night and [__] atlanta
i didn't know what they were going to do
with all this [__] food
they had a bar and it was filled with
sandwiches
surprised me sandwiches i i don't even
know what the [__] they were then there
was four feet of boxes of uh
when you go to a funnel cake fries
which i don't [__] eat that [__] then
they had regular fries then they had
tacos all four flavors shrimp chicken
beef beans [__] rice i mean
it was superb
i had i had no problems with anything
except one thing
i had a little anxiety before i left
because guys i haven't been out of the
[__] house in two years never mind to
bristol tennessee to [__] uh
south carolina and to outside atlanta it
was uh
cold ray stadium or something like that
like
i never been to these [__] i mean
i've been to tennessee and i've been
told so i was a little apprehensive
about my knee my knees been buckling a
little bit like that but i got to tell
you something here's the [__] crazy
thing and you guys i know this has
happened to you you've been worried
about something worried about somewhere
i mean i was just worried about my knee
man i don't want my wife to have to get
me come fly to mississippi or [__]
atlanta to come get me
so
i'm worried about my knee how many times
my knee gave out on me this weekend
zelch all those airports all that
walking those baseball fields hockey
stadiums
all that [__] was solid as a
[__]
now
when bert called me he said listen it's
going to be a [__]
uh a tour bus we're going to get five
tour buses
and he goes they're going to be state of
the art you're going to love them you'll
be fine i got to be honest with you guys
and i'm saying this for mike
we all want to be [__] rock stars you
know you know everybody wants to be a
[__] rock star there's no better life
than a rock star i'm talking about def
leopard [__] 85 you know right before
uh
after pyromania and before the really
good one that they put out and all this
[__] you know these bands think about
being on tour with the [__] stones
in the 70s
with ron wood keith richards
[__] you know
it's like a non-stop party you just sign
up i know you guys saw the motley crew
movie you know
and that's what it's like guys when you
go out for a long period of time it
starts you know when i started coming it
starts tuesday and then sunday by sunday
you're green in the [__] gilts
you have no color in your face you're
just sitting at the bar waiting to do
the last show on sunday night and you're
dying you've been going for a [__]
week straight drinking booze broads coke
pill whatever the [__] they give you you
know what i'm saying but listen today's
a different animal we've all had desires
of being on a [__] tour bus you
imagine that like when you watch almost
famous
you know they want a [__] tour bus
whatever all those
great stories of toys they always had
tour buses and what they do you hear
about john madden traveling with a
[__] tour bus that looks like a
[__] apartment you know
i gotta tell you some something the tour
buses were gorgeous
and i was all the [__] i'm like yeah
a tour bus smelling farts you know
smelling feet
in your [__] bunk just writing stupid
jokes in the middle of night that sounds
like a lot of fun for a [__] guy like
me just tremendous i don't drink or
nothing
you know i'm gonna smoke some dope i'm
not gonna do anything else
but i thought it was a great idea so i
signed up for it no problem
we do the [__] first show thursday
night we fly down
i see mark norman at the airport we fly
down there together
we get to [__] in uh
south carolina we get to the hotel
whatever the [__] they pick me up at 6
30 gorgeous it's gorgeous out
we do the show and then
it was one of the best i couldn't
believe that wednesday night i was in
bed at 10 30
and thursday night
i was out at [__] one in the morning
talking with people
smoking dope eating edibles you know
just everybody was having a good time
because the bus shows up at three to
pick you up
so you got to stay up till three and
just talk [__] with people you know
there was uh what he did was he bought
like uh
bert sold all access tickets
so after the show we had all access
tickets
you could come on up and hang out so i
think like maybe 30 people bought those
tickets
and i got to tell you something
everybody who came up there was [__]
cool i honestly got the rogan
buddy came by just uh these girls from
fort lauderdale came by they were great
i invited them at the hotel they were
realtors all the you know just they sell
like uh property management stuff it was
just really nice people
and three o'clock came we started
getting into the buses talking [__] big
j
mark norman shane gillis we're all on
the [__] bus with bert
and guys i went to i even bert put up a
video of me sitting in the bunk i was
[__] fine guys look at my face i'm
fine
but i mean listen guys i smoke dope in
the morning
and i try to smoke dope in the air like
today i got a little [__] high but at
night
i'm not getting high i'm just chasing
joints one after the other until you you
smoke yourself straight and that night i
popped the edibles when i got off stage
which was maybe
9 15.
so by 12 i'm on fire and then by three i
had cooled down a little bit you know so
i was fine
i was talking with mark he was across
from me i was talking to bert i was
talking to my man [__] uh big j and
also it was time for nappy noodle time
i'm like okay this is gonna work
guys
i [__] got my bunk i plugged in the
sleep apnea machine
i put my little mask on and i was and i
was i was fine and all of a sudden i
slid the curtain
and that's when my world
turned upside [__] down i just guys i
can't even [__] explain it
i'm still drinking liquid iv to [__]
recover
guys my world turned around and then i
remembered in the middle of what i'm
like why am i feeling like this i
started sweating profusiously
my heart was beating out of [__]
control
and i'm carsick but to top it off on the
car sickness
i had about a [__] anxiety because
that curtain closed there was no windows
back there there was nothing it was
nothing but [__] darkness
the first time i walked in that bathroom
i must have fell down two times
i started peeing i was peeing every
seven minutes from the anxiety my heart
was beating so much my body went into
like [__] shock i started peeing
every [__] seven minutes
one p after the other
so
about five in the morning i just started
barfing
i just started barfing
you know water that i drank and all this
[__] and i just did not feel good then
the shirt came off like bert kreischer
sweaty titties were sweating you know
i'm saying when you feel the [__]
water under your tits
at one point i was just laying there so
i had to walk to the front of the bus
while i was car sick guys i
this was the worst feeling i had it was
like vertigo meets vertigo
i had to walk to the front of the bus
with my eyes closed the bus is doing 70
miles a [__] hour i'm hearing guys
snoring i'm here
and i'm like what the [__] i'm hearing
little snores i think it was like big j
we had like a little snow
very light but some other guy was big
whatever and i realized that in the
front the bunks were three
so there was a top bunk a middle bunk
and then a [__] the bottom like
a casket and when i saw that casket i
was like this is [__] i ran out to
that front of the bus
and i sat in the like the bus was
looking straight so
i sat on this side and guys from the bus
going like this like i'm looking out the
window i'm starting to get [__]
sicker i'm just [__] dying i'm just
like what the [__] i can feel the sweat
i can feel the sweat in my ears
when you feel the sweat in your ears you
know there's a [__] problem
so i [__] sat there for like an hour
in a weird position
like with my head on top of a box
and i just was sweating
with my feet up
bent over like legs all crooked and
that's one of the [__] uh
the interns came out one of the guys
that works and he's like dog you don't
look too good i'm like i ain't too
[__] good
so he goes we'll be landing
we'll be getting uh
to tennessee in like 40 minutes so i was
in bristol tennessee
uh they drove me to a hotel guys i could
barely walk upstairs like that's how
[__] up i was like i could barely walk
in the hallway
i went to my room i took a shower i had
a little puke on my chest i had [__]
sweats you know
i took a shower
and i felt a little better i drank a
bunch of water i drank a liquid iv i
brought like 10 liquid ivs with me i
drank a liquid iv because i had sweat
like a [__] animal
and i felt a little better i went
downstairs i had a couple eggs some
bacon and i [__] hit the crib for the
whole [__] day but when i woke up
i had a splitting [__] headache and
uh you know what the show must go on i
must hate like two of leaves i went down
there
bristol tennessee was [__] great i
don't know if you people have ever been
to tennessee
i don't know if you people have ever
been to the south and this is why
this was the best part of me ever doing
comedy it wasn't the shows it wasn't
best part of me doing comedy is i got to
see this [__] country
and i got to tell you something i love
it i love this [__] country i love
spots that nobody else would like what i
like
people think like you're a [__] mutt
dog there's greater cities than that i
don't judge cities by accu uh
architect or the restaurants i judge the
city but i like to feel here i am in
[__] bristol tennessee
and i don't know if you're familiar with
southern hospitality
it is mind-boggling
it is mind-boggling i mean south
carolina was [__] tremendous we
stayed across
a hotel from the uh comedy zone
i had been there earlier i hadn't been
to that club in 15 [__] years i did a
one night of that
maybe in 97 98
but the people at the [__] uh
i ordered a pork taco
in uh like a a carnitas taco in
south carolina guys
and when it came i looked that it was an
appetizer it was two tacos
and when i came i looked at it i'm like
this looks a little weird i've been into
that [__] the first bite the
pork was really good right
i'm like this is okay but this is not i
thought that had some garnishes dog i
took the second bite
and that [__] taco blew up they had
beans in that [__] with some
salsa some cheese i had never tasted
carnitas like that my [__] life and
here i am in south carolina and i've
been to san diego mexico
l.a i've been to every state with his
[__] mexicans i love all four
different mexicans types of food you got
the colorado type you got the [__] uh
new mexico chili that's colorado too
then you got tex-mex i like it every
[__] way but i had never in my life
had a taco as juicy and as delicious as
these two [__] tacos
in whatever south carolina wherever the
[__] i was look at the schedule i was
blown the [__] away blow the [__] away
i'm like i'm thinking i'm eating like
some no it was [__] delicious
and then i had something else like a
cheeseburger or something
[__] on uh
whatever then when they grow the [__]
cow and on grass and they don't kick it
they don't hit it with sticks and [__]
like that or spit balls
the [__] beef was just melting in my
dog this is
and you know what when my tab came guys
it was like 16 [__] dollars
you feel like you're robbing somebody in
these small cities
everybody said good morning everybody
said good night you know this is like
lunch in south carolina and it was
[__]
tremendous i mean dinner
then it was gonna be like at night when
i got to the club and i had worked out
at the hotel and i was [__] starving
so i got i went downstairs and got a
steak in the restaurant again i'm like
i don't know how good this is gonna be
holy [__]
the steak melted in my [__] mouth
like butter you have those steaks that
you don't know what it's gonna be like
it was perfect it was a 10 ounce new
york strip it was perfect
and they made this vegetable medley with
mushrooms and onions and peppers and
cucumbers i didn't eat anything else but
i tore up those [__] onions and
peppers i went to that [__] show i'm
like guys
i just had a steak that had so much
[__] flavor on it and it melted it's
like the beef in these
communities is [__] tremendous
then i went to tennessee
i got up the next morning went to
tennessee that morning i had breakfast
i slept uh you know basically all day
i don't even know what i had later on
the afternoon but when i went down like
it was one of those hotels where i was
like
nobody's gonna say nothing to me in this
hotel
nobody knew nothing nobody knew who i
was
nobody said good morning nobody i said
good morning to them or whatever when i
went upstairs when i left
nobody said a word to me at those hotels
usually there's people at the bar
drinking that are gonna go to the
[__] show but there was nobody so i'm
like wow
this hotel there's nobody here so i
[__] went to do the show when i came
back there was a skinny [__]
waiting for me in the hallways like dog
where you been holy [__] and he was
staying at the hotel i think he worked
there he's like dog i got something for
you
but i already had like uh some edibles
in me i smoked some dope and i
i was still sick from [__] thursday
night's run so i was like dog i'm gonna
go upstairs i think i took uh two milano
cookies they have those two packs the
milano thin ones just to watch tv and
unwind and i [__] passed the [__] out
but when i got up saturday morning i
went downstairs and i went to get
breakfast
and there was this cute little black
lady cute as [__] african-american lady
she had to be 70.
when i was getting some oatmeal she came
up to me she's like excuse me sir
did i see you in the longest yard
and i'm like yes you did she goes my
name is miss turner
i'm the chef here you know anything you
want but my my grandchildren have
watched that movie a thousand times
so i started talking to miss turner and
stuff she was sweeter than pie and then
the girl in the back came out she was
all tatted up she's like are you on
tick-tock
and i'm like
i'm sorry i
even eliza selections you hit me up last
night she's like dawg you're huge you
take that somebody's brother
somebody's running that account and i'm
like wow
so i [__] uh she's like if you want
tick-tock and i'm like i don't know kids
put my [__] up there i'm sorry about the
language she's like nah
i love it so now i'm eating breakfast
and it's all women down there right
there's like
the tattoo chick that thought i was on
tik tok she was like a dishwasher or
something there was another
african-american waitress that was
really cute older you know 50. there was
another african-american lady miss
turner and there was another white chick
that was she came over she's like man
i'm happy you're at the hotel all right
i went upstairs i took my [__] my man
dorfman was there from zanies in
nashville the owner sweetheart of a
[__] guy sweetheart of a guy he goes
dog don't get on the bus i'll drive you
to atlanta
and he's a great guy great club i'm
gonna be out there in december to do
jelly rolls uh benefit in january uh
december 9th i'm going to stop in zany
say hello to dork we had a [__] blast
but when he came to get me
you could ask this [__] i went
upstairs i talked to the women for about
45 minutes he was picking me up like
about 11.
i went upstairs when i checked out
guys as i was checking out this your
uncle joey diaz the dirtiest
[__] in the world
those four women were waiting for me
and i hugged all four of them and
they're like when are you coming back
like they're like you're coming back all
these women were in their 50s and 60s
they're like when are you coming back
son they were like god bless you they
were the sweetest the [__] women they
had no idea i was about to get in the
car and go do [__] [__] jokes and
[__] jokes they thought i was doing
like christian material they they
embraced me i felt so bad for these
women they were sweden in hell
i don't know if you've ever been to
tennessee guy
but this weekend made me realize why i
married my wife this weekend's listen
we're not doing a podcast next week
because the fourth of july i got a lot
of [__] going on next weekend with games
mikey's getting ready to get married he
needs some time off this [__]
drive three hours two days a week you
know
this is my anniversary 22 [__] years
this weekend
and uh
when i was in tennessee i'm like i don't
even end up with this woman you know
and now for a word from our sponsor
better help listen you got to take care
of your mind we spend so much time
taking care of our skin our hair our
teeth our bodies by jumping up and down
but sometimes we miss the most important
part which is the brain
how well you can take care of your brain
affects your experience
in life investing time and energy and
mental health is crucial to be happy
eating right working out getting plenty
of sleep they're all good start but
there's no substitute for talk therapy
guys listen
i've been with better help for about 10
months now maybe a year
she bailed me out from one of the bigger
predicaments i was and i didn't know
what to do next better help makes online
therapy accessible convenient and
affordable
you know i worked with dana for months
we did exercises we talked no medication
all that stuff you just need therapy
you're never gonna find a therapist on
your own they're all busy this is the
best therapy available to you right now
better help is online therapy that
offers video phone and chat therapy
sessions you can choose not to see
anybody on camera it's much more
affordable than in person therapy and
you can be matched with a therapist in
48 hours
joint listeners get 10 off their first
month
at betterhelp.com
joey again that's better betterhelp.com
joey visit betterhelp.com for 10 off
your first month
when you press code joey in there that's
betterhelp.com
joey get your life together
and it's a sweetness thing man i love
women from the south i get along with
them i don't know what it is
are you on ted talk i was [__] dying
i was dying guys
so we headed to [__] atlanta
but i tell you what i'm still getting
messages every day from bristol
tennessee i don't know what i did in
bristol
but i told them that my wife's from
tennessee that a family eats squirrels
and [__] and they weren't [__] off
you know i talked about i really wanted
a piece of lee's fried chicken
but lee's is all the way in milan and in
[__] louisville and
i like nashville chicken but dog unless
you have leaves chicken
don't don't even come talk to me leash
fried chicken dog i'm cuban puerto
ricans make the best fried chicken i
don't give a [__] what anybody tells you
i know you people are going to say
something else because you're [__]
racist no puerto ricans make the best
fried chicken all right
and uh i gotta tell you something when i
just go this times i go to milan
just to eat the fried chicken guys i
won't go to [__] rutherford
to eat chinese food my friends like this
is the best chinese food i don't give a
[__] those days are over when i got good
chinese down here
i won't even go to rutherford dog when
i'm in nashville i drive an hour and a
half guys to two hours
to get a [__] bucket of chicken from
lee's fried chicken
it's so good
it's brothers with no gloves on
just frying chicken with natural
african-american flavors on their
fingers dog and they got some flavor
down there
i learned how to eat from african
americans when i was a kid but there's
two places i remember the food
specifically
tennessee lee's fried chicken and there
was a a heavy brother in dallas
weighing about 500 this [__]
used to make pork chops on a grill
outside
outside the improvs and the uh the other
club in dallas he was really the other
club in dallas
he made he made these [__] pork chops
on a grill on white bread
oh lord
with dirty hands with a towel sweating
on the pork chops
do you hear anything did you hear me say
a word did you hear me say well there's
hair on myself no
excuse me sir you're sweating on my pork
chop that's the [__] flavor that
[__] is 500 pounds jackie doug
ralphie used to cook what do you think
he didn't sweat in the [__] food i'd
see that [__] making gumbo drops
falling off his head that fat that's
better fat than you're gonna get from a
[__] beef or a chicken that ralphie
sweat fat in your [__] gumbo that's
[__] tremendous brother
but atlanta when i got the [__]
atlanta atlanta was [__] rocking
atlanta is a [__]
atlanta
is a [__] uh
it's a city that doesn't stop growing uh
when you go on when you like
it was a minor league field so i thought
we were gonna perform like you know
in some part of georgia where herschel
walked nobody even knows who walker is
and [__] you know one of those places
so
[__] uh i just said herschel walker
because last night i was watching
tv with my wife and there was a channel
that had espn something had the usfl on
from 1985 and herschel walker was
playing for the [__] generals and a
lot of people don't remember that was
who has owned that team
donald trump owned the
usfl jersey generals his first boss his
the guy he drafted was herschel walker
nothing to do with our story i just
figured i'd drop it in there and give
you a little [__] color commentary
we drove down there and we stopped in a
town close to uh
duncan
and i called duncan he didn't [__]
pick up
we were in the town over from asheville
north carolina we went to this [__]
place in there holy [__]
this was like a brewery
like a really like organic hippie
brewery
i got the avocado toast in this
[__]
dog it was tremendous it was the avocado
on the thin bread with the crushed
pepper and the olive oil but these
[__] went the extra step
they threw arugula on that [__] oh [__]
arugula
and then the [__] made me a
grilled fried chicken sandwich
holy [__] it wasn't least no disrespect
but it was pretty [__] good he made
like some orange mustard something god
damn it was [__] good man these they
know how to cook down south that's one
thing i i'm honest with you i've had
some bad meals
in the south sometimes you don't know
but there's some [__] i went to
nashville's one time
you gotta ask my wife there's a
restaurant nashville a steakhouse
they ain't [__] around it now and i
gotta tell you something it was dirt
cheap
that's the [__] uh steakhouse we went
to like four years ago and we brought
our niece and we validate the car and
when the valet took off my niece is like
uncle joey he's stealing your car i go
nah it's a valet doug don't worry about
that we got this
but we went to asheville and it was
[__] great the town over
and then we ended up in uh in georgia
and uh
we drove right to that georgia atlanta
is getting so [__] big it's beautiful
and i gotta tell you what else they got
a lot of in atlanta
beautiful
african-american women are you ready for
this
did i just say beautiful
african-american women and i think they
all work at the [__] airport
they are beautiful and then you're in
georgia and i think you forgot that
those women
are [__] peaches
and the white chicks were smoking
if you're young
and you're handsome and you're looking
for a wife
24 28 you already went to school i would
consider [__] atlanta
there's always something [__] going
on atlanta there was a thousand things
going on and that was us the [__]
braves were playing the dodgers i mean
it's just the people were out when we
drove past that land in the daytime
people were out
it's like a [__] town that p every
time i go to atlanta blo that uh that
theater we did in atlanta two years ago
i was blowing the [__] away and i had
done that theater with joe rogan
20 years ago when brendan sharp was
still [__] fighting
duh whatever [__] theater in atlanta
i don't know what it is but man
that town every time i go there and it's
clean you know i i don't know i didn't
go to the [__] rough and tough areas
i really wanted to go to gladys knight's
uh
soul food kitchen but i don't even think
it's open no more and there's always a
line and [__] like that so
went to the hotel in atlanta chilled and
then we went and did that [__] gig
and atlanta was just i mean
took all the gigs with tremendous they
were just happy
you know for the first time in 32 years
i really got to see the gift of stand up
upon people
you know it's been a rough [__]
couple years and
i agree now people do need to [__]
laugh
and i made some comments on here a
couple months ago maybe a year ago about
people going out and i was wrong
you know man
i see it now i got it after i saw that
festival it looked like a rock festival
guys
looked like a [__] rock festival
you know i went to see ted with uh
aerosmith and pogo and frank marino
mahogany rush in 78 and while i was
sitting there watching burt and all
these guys on stage that's what it felt
like to me
like there was so much warmth in those
there was not one problem guys
there was no hecklers
[__] mark norman did a spot i think
in atlanta
he leveled me
shane gillis is my new favorite [__]
comic unreal this [__] how funny
he is
his trump is [__] tremendous bert did
a tremendous job nikki glazer [__]
had me killing me she did a joke about
[__] this is so weird when you watch
somebody do this
she did a joke about like guys are so
horny and whatever that sometimes she'll
just put a hand out and a guy will [__]
her hand and she won't even have to move
her hand and [__] and after she got on
stage i go nicki
while you were doing that joke i got a
flashback to [__]
tempe arizona in 1997.
i'm in a room with some chick and she's
[__] teasing the [__] out of me she's
doing my coke and stuff
and she showed me like a tit and i was
[__] chomping at the bit and before
she left she's like i gotta go home and
i'm like what the [__] you did my eight
ball nothing not even a ten nothing
and before she left i go [__] it you
don't have to do anything just put your
hand like this and let me stick my dick
in and she's like
you were stooping to the lowest of life
and i know that and then she left and i
never forgot that night that i asked
this chick can i just put it in your
hand for like five minutes that's when
you know
you're [__] disgusting me and nicki
glaze were [__] laughing her ass off
when i told her that
brian simpson is great
i mean it was just a great thing i'm
really proud of burt and i'm happy he
invited me
and i'm happy i went
i i went i was always on the fence but
if it wasn't for [__] you guys
give me the love and then i went and
i think bert was taping every time i
went up on stage to get the audience's
reaction and [__] and all that stuff
feels good you know i did okay
i wasn't
joey diaz powerhouse until maybe
saturday night some started coming out i
mean it was funny i was writing [__] in
a notebook all three days and
nothing i was writing was working but
i'm gonna tell you what happened like i
talked about uh the journaling well i
was writing jokes now i've been here for
two years i can't remember my jokes
all of a sudden they started coming out
saturday night
on stage just just
didn't even and awesome i saw the joke
like in front of me like that and i'm
like okay let's run with this and i ran
it and it worked
there was two jokes i ran this weekend
that were old
i didn't think i even remember bits and
pieces about them and guys
they spit out on my ass like [__]
music the sounds were coming it's it's
it's really amazing how you have to jog
your [__] memory but once it's there
it opens up like a [__] sieve it just
starts coming the [__] out
i tried writing new jokes i wrote a tag
here at tag there but by the time i got
on stage i [__] forgot it anyway
so i just went to what i knew and
saturday night i started coming alive
saturday for me was the show where i
woke up saturday i'm like guys i got to
push the envelope a little bit i hit 15
minutes
on friday night that was my goal 15
minutes stay up there [__] push it
out and then sadly my goal was to really
have a good set and sunday i was like
i'm gonna [__] them up i'm gonna get
this down but then saturday night
we decided i mean this is how cool bert
was burke was like listen bro
i don't want you in the bus especially
tonight to mississippi because that's a
seven hour drive from where they were at
because so do me a favor
they're gonna give you a ride to atlanta
you're gonna stay in a hotel on the
[__] airport grounds
you're gonna wake up it's a four-minute
drive to the [__] airport to atlanta
you're gonna catch the 11 o'clock
flight from atlanta to jackson
mississippi and then you're 15 minutes
away my family was going to come and see
me this weekend i got family in
mississippi
you know when i haven't been to
mississippi to do comedy had to be like
15 [__] years so i don't see them we
talk all the time so that was the plan
about mississippi i was going to see
family down there
i haven't seen him in like 10 years they
came to watch me shoot a movie
in colorado so i was excited about that
so
bert was like just go to atlanta take
the [__] flight we got it don't worry
about nothing
if you don't want to come at 11 come at
two
i was like that sounds [__] fair he
goes two will get you there at three
if not even
it's an hour change but it's still gonna
land at two o'clock like you take off at
two and you land that two in mississippi
so it's perfect i was like i can't
[__] beat that but
that drive to [__] atlanta
killed me that night that 45-50 minute
drive
killed me when i got to the hotel i
started barfing again i had dry eaves
i'm like god damn it and i fell asleep
okay but when i woke up at eight to take
that flight at 11
i got up to pee and i was like
i'm in no [__] danger
i'm gonna switch it to the two so i text
them but i just remembered in my mind
that
they left atlanta at three in the
morning and they had a six-hour drive
so that's seven if they got to stop for
gas and all that [__] so they weren't
even they were still on the bus
so i text them i text the lady who runs
the tour and i said listen man i'm gonna
switch it to two o'clock flight i can't
make the 11. it took like an hour to hit
me back she goes that's fine i'll make
the switch right now so she switched it
to two
i took a shower i had some [__]
breakfast and [__] and i uh
went outside and smoked the number
to get my head together right that's
what you do in the morning i had some
coffee had some breakfast
i want to take a walk around just
exercise my legs before i took any
[__] flight and uh while i was
outside i'm like
i'm not feeling this
i don't feel [__] good at all
and i called the lady
and i said i'm gonna rest for a little
while and see how i feel then my wife
called and we started talking she's like
listen man if you don't [__] feel
good just tell them the truth
and come home
so i go but i gotta meet my family but
when i called my family they were like
hey
we're leaving at about four and we're
getting up there but the weather doesn't
look good up there
i'm just letting you know right now and
i go okay whatever i'm gonna take the
four o'clock flight so i'll get there at
four and then i'll make plans to see you
or whatever okay
when i get to the [__] airport
to take the two o'clock
because i couldn't take it no more let
me just take the two o'clock and get it
over with
two o'clock have been cancelled
delta
canceled
they canceled the shitload of these
[__]
so i told them i asked the lady i go if
i missed the two o'clock i didn't give
him my luggage either
like i had not given him my luggage she
goes to two o'clock might get cam i'm
not gonna lie to you it's gonna be
crammed because you have
the two o'clock people waiting till four
so
we're gonna do standby and we're gonna
give they were giving away 800
to get off the plane they were giving
away
1200 in newark
to get off the plane for a voucher
twelve hundred dollar voucher in newark
but you know what you take that voucher
you don't know what if it's cash because
i said cash and they didn't say no but
if they would have told me cash i would
have taken that 1200 and gotten the [__]
out i would have come home forget about
it things are bad all over i'll see you
next week but they were offering 1200 on
way out of newark
and then when i got down to
atlanta they were like we want we'll
give you eight to get off the plane to
go to jackson mississippi
and all of a sudden me and my wife were
talking she goes joey enough for nothing
there's a there's a two o'clock flight
from [__]
atlanta directly into newark
get you in there four o'clock i'm not
waiting at this airport till four then
they cancel me again and i'm there all
[__] night pass
i call the burp people and i go guys it
does i don't feel good
i'm just gonna find this bad weather i'm
just gonna [__] i
don't i didn't have the energy to fly
all the way to [__]
memphis
mississippi
do the show but get ready for this
i had two options for sunday night
i could get on the bus with those
savages now tonight they were driving
seven and a half hours
that was a seven and a half hour drive
from [__] that part of mississippi
to dallas and then they were gonna get
on the 8 30 flight to newark
direct no problems
or
my other option was plan b
i had three plans plan b was to fly to
jackson
at five in the morning that means i had
to be at the airport at four
to catch a connecting flight to
charlotte
that would put me in newark at 11
and if i didn't want to take that i
could take a six o'clock flight
that would get me into laguardia
at 12 30 or something like that
and i'm like you know what both of those
options ain't gonna work because i'm not
getting [__] stuck on a monday
morning and either charlotte or whatever
and sure enough they grounded a bunch of
[__] flights and fought charlotte
yesterday so knock out wood [__] when
my wife said get the [__] out and come
home i said you know what you're right i
did the three shows you know i'm pretty
[__] happy
[__] it i just don't feel good that
wasn't gonna kill me to do that last
show you guys know i hate working
sundays the whole thing about it
i [__] got on that plane guys let me
tell you something
the plane ride was great
here's your uncle joey advice for the
[__] week guys
if you're thinking of flying this summer
i want you to actually think about where
you're going and what it means to you
because it's going to be a mind [__]
i don't like mine [__] when i fly not
for the money they're [__] charging
i'm not gonna tell you the airlines that
[__] me over on sunday because it
makes no difference they're all
short-handed they're all using the
bottom of the barrel i mean it's not
like you could attack somebody who can
you say something to this is just what
happens these people that had six hour
delays i would hate to be them but this
[__] happens so wherever you're gonna
[__] travel to this summer make sure
it's worth it make sure i'm just telling
you right now because they give you i
don't care whether you're in coach or
first class they give you a bottled
water this small not even a [__] 16
ounce they give you two italian cookies
and a [__] wafer jack and that's what
you're getting for two and a half hours
and that oh
and the surprises keep coming
dog there were filthy people on the
plane there was a lady who was 60 years
old with tats all over her
and she was putting her feet on the
[__] wall she refused to take him
down so the lady told to take it down i
paid for the ticket i deserved to do
this [__] dog listen you gotta have a
little [__] class
you can't put your 50 to 60 year old
disgusting [__] feet on the [__]
wall she was putting them on the tv
which is really unfucking sad i mean
listen i've done it but at my house not
on a [__] plane you dirty old [__]
so this [__] don't want to take her
feet down now and [__] you know she
wants to argue with the [__] lady
back and forth and i'm like lady i will
cut that [__] foot off take it down
because they're not going to [__] let
us fly this went on for like 10 minutes
this is the beginning then they held us
on the tarmac for a [__] hour you're
sweating kids are crying it smells like
yin ying juice in that [__] plane
then we land in newark and they held me
on the tarmac for another hour and 15
[__] minutes guys
again no water no none the store is
coming i'm sorry download the app and
they'll tell you about your connecting
flights if she didn't say download the
app 50 [__] time finally go listen
you download the app and find this a
[__] gate to get into once you do
that she just looked at me and went into
the bag
she could not handle anything this poor
woman i i was sad i even apologized to
her on the way i didn't mean to crack a
joke but well i'm playing an hour later
you're talking about a [__] app
download an app are you kidding me i was
ready to download a gun to shoot myself
in the [__] eye
i'm hearing kids crying that people are
thirsty people are farting they're
getting anxiety phones were ringing
everybody's saying the same thing i'm on
the tarmac 35 [__] minutes now
so i
tweeted i like tweeted there's people
dying in this [__] [__] and two
minutes later they took us to a gate
that's what i do
next time you're on a [__] plane
they're [__] with you live tweet live
tweet name the name of that airline tell
them and i don't it's like you hear one
person crying [__] it say everybody's
crying on this [__] plane because
people read that and they don't want you
to read that that's the last thing any
of these airlines want you to do i see
it all the time when people say on
sunday what the [__] is going on like my
comic friends american airlines we're
stuck here that american will jump right
in and [__] they don't even have to
send a message to them they just put
american addict pops up on them i don't
know how they control twitter you know i
got to talk to elon musk about that [__]
these airlines are controlling twitter
but
i text i got on that [__] thing i
told i'm sorry for cracking a joke she's
like don't worry about it
and they the first they said to me you
can't get off the flight unless you're
connecting and that wasn't gonna work
like i've been on this flight for three
[__] hours
these people who are connecting they're
done anyway i'm getting the [__] out of
when she asked me do you have a
connecting flight to where i go anxiety
and i just walked right past it she knew
what time it was i wasn't gonna [__]
sit there
and i came home and it was [__] great
and then
i'm sitting here feeling a little
depressed i should have stayed
and i got a call
they canceled to show mississippi
my [__] family was right the weather
was gonna affect them
so nobody lost out the date's going to
be redone on september 2nd
and i'll see you [__] in
mississippi on september [__] second
we're going to make up the date then
we're coming back in i think bert's got
atlantic city this week and i'm going to
take him to el nido
i told them i'll do the tour if you go
to el nido because the kids from el nido
really like bert that bird's their
[__] favorite so i told bert you got
to come tell nino so that's the plan and
it all worked out
and if i would have [__] not gone
because of my stupid insecurities or
whatever the [__] i was thinking about
i would have [__] up because i had a
great time it put me back on the map a
little bit on my own
like not back on the map because i'm not
touring but
it put me back on the map for me it let
me off the [__] hook you know
i finally got
i have a great summer coming up i
haven't been excited about a summer
since maybe i was a kid
since i was a kid i haven't been excited
about it or something i never had a
summer that i looked at and said i'm
gonna have a good time i'm gonna have a
good time i got
four or five dates on the books i got
four at uncle vinnie's july sold out i
got two in august that are still there i
got a show i'm doing at asbury park i'm
doing a show in the city and then
whatever else i'm going to pop in
different places i don't want to be
heavy i don't want to work friday nights
i'm not doing any late shows and i'm not
going to be in a hotel all day on
saturdays so
that's it my uh residency starts on
september 17th at the sony theater
uh the first two are saturdays and the
next two uh sundays uh wednesdays
i think november 2nd is a wednesday and
december 28th is a wednesday
it'll be like our new year's for the
year who wants to run on the 31st with a
bunch of amateurs let's do it on a
wednesday and i get [__] up spread
some laughing gas and have a good time
that's what i plan on doing guys i'm
having a great time i'm going to [__]
uh
the ozarks right is that where i'm going
north carolina or some [__] like that
i'm going to the ozarks
yeah i'm going to [__] uh
i'm going with a four or five families
from the neighborhood you know we rented
a big house so
that's my summer and i'm excited
but i'm excited for the next chapter of
my life i i'm happy that i got it all
[__] settled
i'm happy that i know what i want to do
and what i don't want to do
and uh
that's where we're at guys it's just a
beautiful [__] day on a wednesday
and we're wrapping up here because it's
fourth of [__] july weekend
and we got [__] to do and people to see
you know what i'm saying i may go down
to the philly game on saturday we're
thinking about a couple of the
softball parents are thinking of going
down there on philly
on saturday friday i don't know what the
[__] we got we got some little league
all-star games softball game i think
tonight and [__] thursday night i
think i'd like to go down to uncle
vinnie's on wednesday night this week
because thursday they have a private
party and i think most of these clubs
are closed for the [__] weekend i
love to do a spot maybe saturday or
whatever but who gives a [__] it's also
my anniversary man and it's also
my 40th anniversary of not graduating
high school how's that like
this was the week like last week when
i'm in [__] uh i think when i was in
south carolina i looked at the date it
was like the 24th and i'm like wow
it's official i think we graduated on
june 20th i did not graduate i went to
the graduation
because one of my friends was going to
shake the principal's hand with a fake
hand
and then let it go and the principle was
i wanted to see him do it
i went down there i partaked in the
parties and that was uh
one of the best summers of my life 1982
so hopefully i can have a good summer
this year and uh
that's it you bad [__]
again i'm sorry i didn't have a podcast
for you on mondays on patreon instead of
doing the joey diaz project on tuesday i
did it monday just to let them know that
we're going to be all right
today i got you guys last night at the
amp show or monday night
you know every time i do an amsterdam i
got 100 more people so i want to thank
you guys for
supporting me on that but you got to
start by down
loading the app please it costs you
zero zero zero zero you're just doing me
a favor you guys like music you know i
like music last night we had a great
time we played [__] cake we played a
fake dr dre
some [__] guy saying mr bust up the
[__] guy couldn't shake himself down
i played some [__] good music last
night some gin and jo i didn't want to
play jenna juice i played dr dre day and
that was great i don't know which song
was bad but man
amp got a selection of great [__]
jams
if you're like me we've all dreamed of
being a [__] dj at one time or
another all of us you know i grew up
listening to new w
i grew up listening to wbls i still use
one of the lines from wbls when you used
to
check out on sunday nights he used to go
i got to take two steps to the rear and
get out of here i'm in the wind later i
love that [__] and then some guy came on
you could be what you want to be
do what you want to do
donate to the church some guy used to
come on on sunday nights that's when i
turned that [__] off but i always
remember one of the dj you know i loved
it we all saw good morning vietnam how
fun it is amp is [__] fun guys you're
gonna [__] love it you're gonna knock
yourself the [__] out with it the first
time i did it was a little on the rough
side but guys if i could figure it out
and i could pick the songs and set the
[__] show and [__]
a person with no [__] eyes could do
it that's how stupid i am when it comes
to the computer and you do it for an
hour and just tell stories tell stories
about your favorite songs and how they
became your favorite who gives a [__]
this is for you people that are always
complaining that nobody helps you it's
time to help yourself
download the app create your own radio
station listen you can talk about sports
i don't care if you don't like music
they have life and leisure [__] they
have entertainment you can do whatever
the [__] you want on there
but get your voice out there you want it
to be heard for years you type it people
go [__] yourself this is your chance
this is your [__] chance
this isn't about me this is what when i
found this app i'm like dog i know a ton
of guys
on my instagram on my [__] patreon
they love [__] music even if they
don't want to listen to me at least you
could start your own [__] thing and
it costs you dick there's no excuses you
can't do it to an android right what's
up
no android and no uk yet
let's blow this [__] up
and then they'll cater i'm not making a
dime on this guys this is a labor of
love for me anybody who creates a
program this easy
so you can go on there and tell your
[__] story what are you [__]
kidding me i'm not making a dime on them
i'm just doing it i think it's fun
i think this app is going to go
somewhere and i got to be honest with
you guys
by the looks of things i
i'm going to do this at night this is a
great thing to do at night
you know maybe i don't want to do it i
usually do them at eight and that's a
waste of time because it's five la times
so i'm kind of [__] with them
what i think i want to do with it is
like maybe a sunday at 11 so l.a people
could listen to it or maybe a sunday at
10 and i got best of both worlds
california people you can't watch 60
minutes that's when i'll tell uncle joy
to go [__] himself i always got to watch
my 60 [__] minutes
anyway
thank you very much for watching the
show this week again i'm sorry about
monday we'll be back monday july 11th
but all my action will be on patreon all
week if you miss me that much but you
[__] ain't gonna miss me that
much i love you with all my heart
stay black have a great weekend have a
happy fourth of july salute the [__]
flag
and i'll see you [__] on the
11th of july
tip top magoo stay black [__]
all right you bad [__] i want
to thank you
i want to thank my man mike and all you
[__] for listening this week
sorry about monday i was on the road and
busy but we're back and we're taking
next week off but we'll be back on the
11th of july this weekend the joint is
brought to you by ufc 276 and draftking
sportsbook the official sports betting
partner ufc new customers can bet five
hours on any fighter and get a hundred
and free bets win or lose whether it's
either sonia with a knockout kick or a
powerful punch from kenia you win no
matter what with draftking same game
paulie you could turn a small bet
into a big payday combine multiple bets
which the fighter that will win number
and knockouts more listen these prop
bets on draftkings are killing
[__] download the draftkings
sportsbook app today use promo code joey
bet 5 on any ufc fighter to win and get
a hundred and free bets no matter what
that's code joey this saturday at
draftkings sportsbook the official
sports betting partner of the ufc the
joint is also brought to you by better
help
listen you got to take care of your mind
eating right working out and getting
plenty of sleep are good but there's no
substitute for talk therapy and you
never know when you need it better help
makes online therapy accessible
convenient and affordable i had a
problem
and i spoke to somebody i spoke to dana
i worked here for about a year i'm still
there and i love it i'm better you guys
can notice it i'm flowing i'm happy
and that's the bottom line better help
is online therapy that offers video
phone and chat therapy sessions you can
choose not to see anyone on camera it's
much more affordable than in-person
therapy and you can be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours
joint listeners get 10 percent off their
first month at betterhelp.com
joey again
that's betterhelp.com
joey
[Music]
dot betterhelp.com slash joey for 10 off
your first month
the joint is also brought to you by cbd
lion the best when it comes to cbd
four years running with me they nursed
me through a knee a [__] shoulder a
pulled hamstring
and my health every day hey listen the
cbd lion
is tremendous i like the tension i like
the delta eight products whether it's
the gummies
or the tincture or the kinesiology tape
or the gummies with melatonin cbd lion
has it all
go to cbd line read the third party lab
results
add code joey and you're rocking and
[__] rolling i love you have a great
weekend i want to thank draftkings i
want to thank better help and i want to
thank cbd lion for having my back
stay black have a great weekend and i'll
see you guys in 10 days
i'm gonna miss you [__]
you